[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dear LeBron I'm sorry this had to happen
this way but I didn't tell you sooner
claiming the O'Brien Throne with you was
one of the proudest moments of my life
and I will be forever grateful for the
lesson
[Music]
I can no longer fight in your shadow
sure we had our differences but the real
problem is that were very much the same
many men succumbed to the law of rings
and super teams only to obscure a deeper
desire to be the man while this chapter
comes to a close a new door is opened
beyond which lies the knowledge of my
true potential I may find that I was
mistaken that I needed you all along or
maybe I'll discover that I'm more
powerful than I ever dreamed and so I've
set sail for the edge of the world but
if I find that this world is indeed
round
and maybe one day my journey will lead
me back to you
in my stead awaits another you may
recall his words from Nastya
well his wish has been granted there
will be a new king
[Music]
King James is late to his own meeting it
doesn't bode well for us getting out of
this slump hopefully he's finalizing a
trade for Kevin am i right
freaking Kevin
[Music]
bring out your bosses bring out your
boss we'll take your whip draft picks
and bloated contracts will pay heaps of
gold on the back end for your mediocre
youngsters ring out chip off yeah you
can have him after all right every is
the noid of craps you should have been
here all along I there you go for your
troubles all right off we go welcome
ma'am
well thank you bus for a small fee so
Lowry allowed to see you in a nets tunic
not me him ah that also does all things
no the guy on the horse ah side of RA
Carol
oh boy that contracts are doozy afraid
I'm gonna need a couple draft picks to
take him on fine but just keep this
between us I know I know I get a lot of
Jerry's unblemished record source
Castillo and sir aquifer very nice what
no cause he says he's not our boss oh
he's a bust all right so you're just
gonna send me off to Brooklyn just like
that yes it'll be a fresh start
well why not ball stone you look Julia
I've tried everywhere that's kusa well
I've just been in a bad situation you
couldn't even beat out a rashon hole
maybe if I had some veteran leadership
or some archers to space the field he's
got a point there I roll out of bed and
get 20s and Tony the only thing you get
out of bed for is a cheese stick not
true and vegan now I'm gonna best
shaping me live see look at me I'm being
a jock look I'm getting back on defense
can you please take this guy the scribes
are killing me I'll throw in a second
round I'll take anything in return
how about this guy who he's good on day
and has 18 businesses
do your job no it's fine
deals done all right enjoy trevor booker
bring out your bosses bring out your
bosses will take your whip tropics and
bloated contracts
[Music]
stay extends nicolas north going off his
numbers from last year you could make
the cases become one of the best
shooters in the realm you can never have
too much shooting Steph clay your
thoughts oh yeah oh yeah I think it's on
safe a bit shaky
I think swaggy P could be an asset look
Amanda yes Patrick Raven just came in
which Sean's bomb household it has
traded for Dwight Howard good for them
nothing to concern ourselves with Thank
You Patrick let us know if you hear of
anything else
hi Lord Commander swaggy has his moments
but all too often plays the fool they
said the same of Javel but I'd say he's
worked out quite nicely I just I worry
how many of these Jester types can we
absorb until yes Patrick
another raven he's crossed the Narrow
Sea who fur can 48 fur Ken cork mouths
so Patrick they say you might make the
sixes active roster hope okay Patrick
maybe just notify us if any big names
change houses understood right right
big names got it awful one think Nick's
presence will help he's one of the best
catch and shoot guys out there I and law
Walton speaks well of his defense I mean
I like the Lord it's just many other
Ravens sure it is Russ but it's a big
name hall-of-famer okay Vince Carter
he's joining house Kings were not
worried about house kings Patrick Byrne
punch but you said big names and four
years old Patrick I don't know I just
gets a bad feeling about him yeah how
about this only inform us of anything
that actually matters to a house of our
stature so say one of the Great Houses
of the West makes a move that directly
affects us that sort of thing right
something that hurts our chances right
got it if you think it's a good fit
that'll know his role you may be right
this is not the swaggy P of your he's
known his uncle swaggy now all right
so disagreed he'll be examined by the
maces on the morrow and if they deem him
fit that a contract
I've got major news multiple references
better be good yes sir Chris Paul has
been traded to house rockets but wait
there's more
Jimmy Butler is joining Carl Anthony and
the maple night in Minnesota yeah and
there's more it's worse Paul George and
Carmelo Anthony will be joining the
Brody on house Thunder that's three new
super houses Hall in the West again
Patrick please only bring us news that
actually affects our chances
[Music]
when will Lord Sava and your master of
basketball operations be arriving
they've entrusted me as emissary now
what is this trade thread no we've come
to discuss an alliance Alliance how
would that even work
think of it more as a merger
individually our houses are weak but
together we could dominate the West as
house kings swords I love it hold on but
what if I told you you could play
alongside the next death curry right
it's just the name King sons it's
awkward
what about sudden Kings okay fine
from here on we were House Sun Kings
okay we're the Sun Kings we've taken the
liberty of drafting a standard for our
new combined house buddy flip it one
more I can't really see the Sun wood
it's at the front of the ground excuse
me I was thinking maybe what I was
thinking maybe a crown inside a Sun like
a fiery crown I like that Thanks sure
love to paint so I think of all the
compositions
I think it's frayed we want that the
flaming crown come on buddy it bogged in
spent like three practices stitching
this together so I need to find my lord
it is a small price to pay for a
dragon's dragon yes everyone is actually
quite keen to have a look you mean
trogon what I mean here is a [ __ ] dragon
where's its wings scales still
developing you guys come on oh I see so
the dragon is actually a person great
job researching bloody really good
researching there I didn't realize I
just read the notes the scouts gave me
they said dragon did you draft the Aaron
Fox because you thought it was a fox
foxes are smart it's fine it's fine
we can evaluate all our assets when we
join forces in Sacramento
you mean in Phoenicia oh for heaven
sakes we just built a state-of-the-art
castle isn't Sacramento bit smooth just
to go to finish so what it's hundred
twenty degrees every day it gets cool at
night and besides do you expect us to
abandon a city with such a rich
basketball history
well clearly
not familiar with the rich history of
house Kings Lord Commander Adrian and
his Salomon corner AFET oh come on they
don't even compare to D'Antoni's seven
seconds unless a fat suit okey we had
Chris Webber say Charles is better
that's the ridiculous man Webber was
bigger he was more athletic not even
close man and you had nothing like pay
just for our garbage he was no Dan
Majerle right this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about that Marley Dan
Majerle was trash man and I suppose
you're going to say the same of Steve
Nash the Kings have never come close to
salad like that what about the white
knights of chocolate wait wait wait did
you just compare Jason Williams to Steve
Nash have you gone mental Steve Nash
never did in elbow Pass who gives a [ __ ]
what do you know about passing ball all
right enough enough maybe we are a bunch
of balls and maybe it is bloodier than
Phoenicia and sure Sacramento's small
the Tucson I mean know where it is be
honest but if we put aside our
differences and combine our houses
well then still probably wouldn't make
the playoffs foot boy well when I look
around I see a bunch of guys who I may
not know their names and they may not be
good but they play basketball I think
and Eric make your point I guess my
point is I don't know I don't wanna be
here
[Music]
wake up Yanis tell you something what is
it Bango fall off the ladder
no going to exile you at dawn I knew
this day would come
demand a trial a trial by one on one I
will be your champion
Yanis you're good oh you're a good kid
it's not right they blame you for
everything the analytics maesters blame
you for other countries we give up I
mean it is my defensive schemes and the
fan links says your fault we don't know
what to foul in the last two minutes of
battle okay I mean that even though half
tonight I've given up on you
eleven of them actually yeah always a
breakfast movie something longtime
bassist I could adjust my schemes I
could stop blaming our youth I could
even work on my time management but I
won't because at the end of the day I
must be true to who I am in here and in
here I am an [ __ ] I'm a stubborn
[ __ ] and I don't have a clue what I'm
doing good but you're the best Lord
Commander I've ever had I'm the only
lord commander you've ever had where did
you us you're giving up on me don't cry
over spilled media honest life gives you
spilled need
using to get a free time now the big dog
Glenn Robinson when aus box finest
nights I fought beside him under our Sox
years ago Luke Amanda never talked about
him
but sometimes I'd find him down here
lighting candles and praying to the
statue
those weren't prayers they were curses
Sir Glenn Robinson was the first pick of
his draft glass you know who was second
Luke remember I my laksa Lord Commander
they would come down here to pay as
disrespect that resentment that anger
our circuits greatest weapon and its
greatest weakness
we were just getting comfortable a
scheme so Ray Allen it was pretty
comfortable fighting under George Karl I
spent years on the brink of conquering
the east together but they never did
things grew toxic five years later ray
was finally a champion under maester
rivers his six Lord Commander his an
assert Jordan was a great night underdog
Collins but it was under the Zen master
that he became a champion don't forget
about Steph Curry Mike come on Shirley
he was quite comfortable with Mike
Jackson but Steve Kerr really put him
over the top
what are you even doing down here I'll
just stand here scrapping around
actually found a pretty cool cave you
guys want to come check this out
Wow what is this place this must be
pretty merger each house Hawkes maybe I
don't know start you start we'll
distribute in my George Mikan the first
giant what is this look at all these
pears walls oh my gosh these must be a
white man in a forest probably heard
about them in stories they were the
first to play this game looks normal to
me look here no three-point line they
were too weak to shoot over here some of
these guys weren't even full-time
Knights there were tooth wasters and
they weren't playing and this thing must
be thousands of years old
oh look over here this guy's holding a
basket this looks like their barodius
trying
oh yeah that must be my Stern eye Smith
Wow legend has it he settled baller Osen
made our holy spot he's the father of us
all yeah yeah look it says he thou maker
that's him
that's not that's a start
psalm a third well Jason how old did you
say this was again
[Music]
Oh what happened to Lord Commander we
okay he was attacked at the end of the
fourth quarter for the Jester all the
rivers boy laughed I will break their
ankles neigh neigh neigh neighs a mule
attention I get it I mean no violence is
not the answer but sometimes it is its
funeral Chris you know the gates of
stables Castle are impregnable there are
other ways here a house clipper share
their castle wood house Lego which means
doubly fortified walls they were then
reinforced to protect Toby from shock
after his exile and then re reinforce
the protect Coby with Dwight and then
our Erie reinforce the deck Toby been
trying to unretire it won't be easy
I'll need our best five so that's me
James Clint
Trevor Eric and Ryan Wade no we need
someone expendable a journeyman you
what's your name
green fur just learn to tango you're in
the stables Castle has a secret back
entrance a wheelchair ramp built for
support Pierce synchronize your son dies
if you time it right we can slice
through their lazy zone defense at the
rear gates back to our cart exactly but
we'll need a distraction that's where
you come in Clint I'm here from peak
boleros Brad would you be interested in
purchasing some boots how much for the
shadows great choice actually on sale
for 400 gold why above the back door is
a small window that leads to Donald
Sterling's secret roost where he would
send his racist Ravens it's easy to spot
because all his birds were white hoist
me up and I'll sneak in and unlock the
door wait aren't you on house Rockets if
you are
please take me with you why is he taking
so long do you think you got caught
welcome to the stables castle once
inside we'll have to walk on eggshells
you see Sterling's roost is now the
chamber of Chuck the Condor the most
horrifying mascot in the realm all right
now you lead the way me why me do you
want a guaranteed contract
yeah but then dukedom go
you just take that journey me boy oh no
he's coming back
[Applause]
hunting for fowls
it's what I do I don't know condors even
considered fowl
whoa and one we then descend past Phil
Jackson Zen garden and into the shrine
to Kobe built by Kobe to honor himself
now what I don't know they're supposed
to be a secret passageway James check
his closet
nothing just some skeletons Trevor okay
eight it's got to be a wait hold on hold
on it could be fired for each
championship no it's 81 Kobe scored 81
absurd Jalen the knight of roses horse
yes yes he values individual
accomplishments above all others 8 1
[Music]
Trevor are you gay I'm suspended go on
without me
finish what we started better him than
us I suppose this will take us to the
lucky losers
now in the event that we encountered the
Jester we implement operation generous
thanks for coming out so much Squire
here some of the older blogs take me to
a whorehouse
can't I just cross him up or something
James we've been through this
you were wine and how and the gods would
be all over us it's true
no one can win like Blake he's the best
second best second best sorry alright on
with the dress and off with the beard I
don't know it's not just a beard I am
the beard do it for Lord Commander
goodbye old friend
European Apes and your pubes you look
stunning
I just I don't know if I can do this
don't worry James instead of acting like
you're getting fouled just act like
kendall Jenner hey baby
Kendal what are you doing here I came
here to dunk
I'm Amy talk but but I'm at work will
you haven't been rebound
you haven't been responding to my Ravens
I don't think you sent me any Ravens I
was gyro stepping I mean I was Europe
modelling I mean I was in Europe I was
modeling in Europe you see I'm an
influencer model Kendra are you okay
sorry I mean a feeling little weird
I'm James hearted I mean I'm Kendall
kardashian-jenner that's when I make the
move
usually during something I should have
done a long time ago gotcha [ __ ]
my home island grows near when we get
there my brothers will must-do in each
of you great knowledge hopefully turn
this season around I don't see anything
before you see them
and you'll hear them
[Music]
what is that some sort of chant
it's a rant van Gundy and Ron Tobias
these monks have taken a vow of no
silence
[Music]
here's a question
that's lovely I come listened a lot four
minutes before getting annoyed oh there
she is
the Ayala fan Gundy home sweet all
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
haha brother Stein brother Joe the hell
are you the whole fat review systems a
mess nobody listens to me how are you
I'm miserable we're stuck in the damn
nine season I've tried everything could
use a bit of your help brother chef
father Van Gundy and MOX will always
help a coach in need nights Detroit came
here in form of wall I want you to meet
my brothers this is Jeff Van Gundy
hello their butts Ethan Van Gundy
pleasure to meet you rev Van Gundy that
there's John Van Gundy greetings
I'm their second cousin this little guy
is Gundy Van Gundy he's severely good
indeed so don't say nothing about load
management a Fuhrman can you show
tonight stutter chambers a training
begins bright and early tomorrow you
can't make a free throws they're gonna
hack y'all game I don't know I just sort
of feel like I don't need analytics to
tell me LeBron is good you know I know
that I can see that I'm just not sure
I'll be enough brother Jeff the Lords of
Detroit will have me head if we don't
make a run in the playoffs this year you
know there is another option I mean you
are the master of trades right huh well
I hear whispers of a wealthy Lord is
looking to part ways with his most
decorated night if I send a raven now
they could be here on tomorrow oh hi hi
juice ah screw it sander even I think
you're gonna like him brother Stan he's
even Balder and louder than I
developing developing developing pliers
let's make a try buy me sir Blake
Griffin
but he's the face of your franchise and
soon he could be the face of yours right
but who would you want for him the bias
is a good developing player yes him all
right you got yourself a deal Avery
Bradley
Boban the Giant and a first-round pick I
mean that's quite a lot what kind of
contract you got him under five years
171 million seven thoughts all of gold I
mean sir Griffin's a marvelous talent
and all do you know he once dunked over
a horse Clydesdale wow that's really
athletic
I just hundred and seventy 1 million
gold it's a low and did you know he's
funny
oh no Blake tell us one of your jokes
home sure yeah
so cheers thanks for coming out everyone
so my Squire year some of the older
blokes take me to a whorehouse that one
not that one right um so a ref walks
into a bar and then a table and then
some chairs Oh who's that f is blind
that's great Larry huh it's a deal
[Music]
ferdi well house pistons and remember
stay away from those analytics folks
hahaha
[Music]
were they doing not there is the
ceremonial exodus of the van gandhi's
please give our tidings to the maiden
Rihanna I don't think she's have made it
is what I've got a feeling we're gonna
have a long but I'd future together
Blake
[Music]
sir kristaps are you excited about your
new Lord Commander phys Dale looks like
House Knicks won't be getting rocked
anytime soon ah man don't listen to it
crows are all liars well okay not all
crows I know a story about a bird his
name was Larry and his hair was fair
just like yours but he had a third eye
that could see into the future also a
bad back I hate your stories I know a
story about a child who hated stories I
also know a story about the Chris
child's who punched Kobey's I could tell
you about sir Ewing the sweaty those
were always your favorite does one of my
favorites I could tell you the tale of
star berry shagging and his wagon with
the marketing apprentice is this the
sort of salacious and flirtatious story
you like no maybe you'd like a scary
story
you could scare me Walt quiet whatever
your name is there is nothing more
frightening than being the second option
to Carmela in the Triangle oh my sweet
Latvian child what do you know about
fair fair is for the elders who suffered
through the entire reign of James Dolan
Fanning's are born and live and die or
without seeing a playoff win or a decent
draft pick it was in this darkness that
Isaiah Thomas gave a five-year contract
to roam big snacks James who exactly
that is the time for fear my lanky Lord
watching Stephon Marbury Steve Francis
and Jamal Crawford three shoot first
guards try to coexist in the same
backcourt
traffic's busting in their cribs bloated
contracts for bloated players women
smothered their babies rather than see
them watch any car
get paid sixty billion goatee frickin
lemon cakes on the bench don't get me
started with bargnani fear is the Lord
Dolan cling loot and having to tell him
he's wrestling and dancin when inside
you're crying and dying but you keep
lying and complying because it's
terrifying
oh did I just hear Lord darling roll
rolling
hello yes it is i lord Dolan just wanted
to stop and sing christop say a little
cheer up song oh how delightful and
excite form better find sense
a good place to cry coolers were not
going to tank or play Frank Neil Akina
whose moody is a guy there to find a
cept good place to pray for all your
sins will I overpay Trey Burke or let
him walk away like Jeremy Lin thank you
and no please do not welcome back maybe
I'll resign Jarrett Jack
hello pay the luxury tax to give Tyreke
Evans a max five-year contract I should
bring us a yeah Thomas back and the
small one too for a longer deal I think
y'all furred Peyton is the next Bradley
Beal all right Chris laps pours [ __ ]
time for you to hurry up and heal a
little birdie told me physically it's as
European big men talk to you later buddy
see you Lithuania where's Oh Cleo nakum
[Music]
come on Ben
take a free pointer what are you afraid
of oh right the fact that it definitely
won't go in this guy talks more trash
than a young Kobe it also takes more
bird shots than the old one least I'll
take shots penny one point alright just
roll some of us actually have real games
to play rude or fake the person enjoyed
the line for that's a turnover Oh
mistakes like that can cost you Squire
the year but I guess you can always try
again next year whose turn is it
I think it's false Europe and I thinks
I'm not ready what's happening here wait
you got the new 1k yeah just came out
but it's the owners season well they've
got a handcar for the graphics lanza how
is it it's pretty realistic except they
made my hair look painted on that's
because it does look painted on oh says
Monalisa over here well can I see mine
sure let me find it it's Gordon Heywood
Derrick Rose klay Thompson whoa graphics
are uncanny oh here you go
fan Lonzo oh thanks wait I think that's
Michael carter-williams very funny Lonzo
your ratings actually pretty solid but
what about mine you know this doesn't
look anything like me
I guess they got lazy it's all the work
of the drift well what's my writing 272
what I'm a 72 in lonzo's an 80
weren't you in a plot II egg last year
yeah but it was like a special magical
thing it's probably changed it's just
that we haven't got the update raven why
don't you just create your own night huh
I suppose I should oh one of those
those are your default on Kate boots you
start with them now hey little me can't
be seen in these come on now you can
purchase swag for your character from
Ronny 1k over there but I warn you it
gets expensive but 500 covers for boots
that's madness well you can't put a
price on style I'm gonna fancy up my
character don't start without me all
right hey you Ronny 1k that's right
phone oh yeah well I'd like to try out
some of your haircuts please no samples
you try you bye come on well then I'd
like your finest fur coat for my lizard
night that'll be 100 BC what's V see
virtual Karpis
okay here now see these are real coppers
we only take virtual coppers within how
do I get virtual coppers you pay me real
coppers are you right so can I get 100
virtual coppers there you are it's empty
well that's because you just went and
spilled them all over the floor in
bounce alonzo what do I do
first cool what you move you're on a
team with cooze and Donovan marquel you
ready no okay I'll send a full court
pass to Mitchell all right roll for it
okay now I've picked up all 100 of my
virtual coppers off the floor and I'm
handing them to you please give me the
fur coat nice try what you're free short
so after the battle you run into Matt
Barnes he asks you if you'd like to join
him on a 95 mile quest to kick derek
Fisher's ass do you say eh
violence is never the answer or be but
sometimes it is oh seven houses just so
boring
can we skip this nope sorry according to
the rules you can't skip the would
cutscenes alright pure shop demigod
alpha dog with limitless range y'all a
barbecue chicken damn coos and it only
cost me twenty thousand coppers and
three meat goats or Artoo's get in pulse
the game is almost over you sure you
don't want to sub in okay I'm ready
has he put up Jimbo top of key oops
all right my fault two points away from
the win
I want to dunk over Ben Simmons uh you
know I'm a wee bit taller than given
heart right I will find out real quick
boom 18 I win
who says I'm not Squire the year
actually no you miss one an 18 yeah I
mean your donk rating that says here
your dunk ratings only 50 a meter or a
20 to pull up the stunt like that but I
talked to mine or I won the bloody don't
count at least I still haven't received
an update hey Ronnie
bloody 1k server Ravens a bit by the
time that update gets here I've already
won Squire of the year may I just
mentioned that I'm the third leading
scorer on the second-best house in the
East despite devastating injuries to our
finest Knights I think that deserves
some consideration well if either of
your houses were in the West you
wouldn't even be considered for Squire
of the year stop your squabbling
children the term Squire of the Year
award is overrated by this time next
year nobody will even remember who won
oh yeah and who the hell are you
[Music]
but why must you leave I'm a free agent
now will you be back I one way or
another but but where will you go I'll
raise the sails of me art and let the
winds of Destiny blow early you're
wearing a lake of cynic
well yeah hope you realize how sneakers
are bad right rosenmeier years have come
to accept they'll lose in the playoffs
no matter where I go but Los Angeles has
a beach right well I must be going
through Runyon seasons upon us come on
now Russ don't worry I'm not gonna go
anywhere
[Music]
you're wondering why I brought you all
here after all we just had a feast to
celebrate our number one seed and since
when does old Drake give two feasts in a
single fortnight
well it's no good being Lord of the six
if you can't celebrate a first-round
victory with you rose the great Knights
house Raptors sure the scribes they
don't want to talk about us some dingy
house in the north they all just want to
talk about the process and the washed-up
King LeBron
and I say LeBron can have his stupid
feast this year the North will feast on
these first a toast
no more that southern horse piss proper
wine for proper nights
courtesy of your champagne puppy stand
together no over everything
[Music]
are you not wasting good wine on a damn
horse
yeah to the men who slaughtered the
Wizards in only six games yes yes cheer
brave men all of you took six games to
be the house that had three less wins
this year than the Nuggets haven't you
little northern nice killing College
means nothing if you can't fell the king
am i dying no we're just joking you get
used to it
when people ask you what happened here
tell them King James still rules the
east also tell them I'm better than
Michael Jordan
King James has slaughtered the Raptors
in four battles but I thought the
Messiah Ujiri could walk on water any
other master trades would be George King
then conquered bostonia after grueling
seven battles ceiling is still lower
than false
what's this Bryan Colangelo was dumb and
his collars are too big oh thank you
Honest Abe
Bryan is a class act you know when my
wife decided to raise the burner Ravens
I had my doubts but I've really grown to
love you all even you Little Jacob Ruben
filler one two three four five six seven
did someone mention me your will Lord
Hankey is better and smarter than you
Eric jr. Eric jr. what's this
The Curious Case of Bryan long collars a
busy base the Dietrich of the ringer
Gilda's published a paper accusing you
of using federal agents
is this true what no that's ridiculous
I'm sorry Honest Abe where is he getting
all this some analytics where's that did
it analysis of the scrolls analytics
wizard No
[Music]
that you Lord Ange
Gordon another late night of board
gaming huh all right Terry I think maybe
you're taking the scary thing a bit too
far no peace what are you doing
[Music]